Estou aqui porque acho que vocês estão todos
loucos, essas foram as palavras que ouvimos
quando em São Francisco em janeiro, quando o Sr.
D Hawk realmente respondeu a uma
pergunta que fizemos a ele, queríamos
saber por que ele concordou em vir  e se encontrar
com a gente e essa resposta foi é
porque eu acho que você está todo louco eu Chris
aí eu não tenho ideia se você é louco ou
não mas tenho quase certeza que quando o
campeonato chegar aqui você vai estar e
se você perder  você pode ser louco, mas se
você ganhar, certamente ficará louco. Eu não
deveria falar sobre futebol, mesmo
que eu adorasse, estou aqui para falar
sobre cultura de aprendizado e como criar
uma cultura de aprendizado forte e impactante
e como  aumentar a capacidade de mudança
falar sobre cultura de aprendizagem é muitas
coisas, então vamos nos concentrar nos
fundamentos o que é mais importante os
valores os princípios e o senso de
direção o que é a
paleta do caos a paleta do caos é uma abordagem polímata para
promover liderança e
empreendedorismo  é um híbrido entre
uma escola de negócios e uma escola de design,
oferecemos uma educação que não é
tanto apontar para os alunos onde
deve haver no futuro, mas sim
dar a eles a chance de co-criar seu
próprio futuro, trata-se de aproveitar  ao
seu potencial e ajudá-los a fazer o
bem e a fazer o bem é encontrar
essa faísca, essa criatividade, permitindo-
lhe encontrar uma direção e apoiá-los para
ir até lá, isso é o que é o palácio do caos
em 1997,
desde 1997, nós  temos a tradição de que
os alunos, a equipe de alunos, vão a
um ponto de sal criativo em algum lugar do
mundo que chamamos de posto avançado por três
a quatro meses para ir lá para conduzir
e se envolver em diferentes tipos de
projetos um hotspot criativo é uma cidade ou
um lugar que passa por grandes mudanças e
em 1997 era São Francisco
por que fazemos isso bem se você se move de
um território familiar de um contexto que
você conhece muito bem para
um território desconhecido muitas coisas acontecem  n o que
você dá por certo não existe
há novas suposições, novos valores, atitudes,
normas e você precisa escanear e se adaptar a
isso muito rápido, então o posto avançado nos oferece
a oportunidade de passar da nossa
zona de conforto de cones para uma zona um pouco estendida
nesses postos avançados normalmente também
construímos uma tarefa para toda a equipe
algo que une tudo isso em
São Francisco também queríamos um cliente
alguém que pudesse colocar um pouco de peso
na tarefa alguém poderia estar
levando um tipo diferente de
seriedade e um nome surgisse  veio
à tona o nome do Hulk e o que ouvimos
soou fantástico e nós realmente queríamos
ele a bordo havia apenas um problema que
ele não estava interessado ele não estava
interessado em nada ele disse que
não faria isso se você quiser fazer isso
um depende de você eu não estou dentro depois de algum
tempo ele começou a se aproximar e
eventualmente ele aceitou eu não tenho certeza
se ele realmente estava interessado desde o
início se ele estava apenas jogando conosco ou
se h  Ele realmente estava interessado
no início naquela sala de aula quando o
conhecemos, ele começou
aproximadamente algo como este
palácio do caos' então você sabe o que é isso e
ele tirou o cartão Visa do bolso
e ele o segurou assim e  ele
disse você sabe o que é isso e todos nós
não isso sim certamente sabia o
que era então ele disse você sabe quem o
CEO visa e todos nós não não faço ideia ok
você sabe onde fica a
sede não não  pista você sabe quem é o dono da
Lisa não nenhuma pista você conhece alguém que
realmente trabalha no visto não nada ok
então você sabe que o cartão visa você pode
usar para obter dinheiro
e pagar por coisas e serviços mas na
realidade você não sabe nada sobre isso sim
é só isso e ele disse no ano passado que
tínhamos uma receita de um zilhão de bilhões de
dólares e de repente o silêncio caiu
na sala de aula e ele disse
que eu fiz aquele cartão Visa minha
experiência e meu conhecimento sobre como você
pode ir para  criar
transformações massivas  informação sobre mudança institucional
está disponível você está interessado isso é o
que você pode chamar de um ótimo discurso de vendas a
partir disso estávamos todos no que D
Hulk e visto têm a ver com
cultura de aprendizado você pode perguntar Eu voltarei um
pouco mais a isso  mais tarde, mas primeiro por que
aprender cultura por que você deveria se importar por que
isso é importante toda a
educação das organizações, assim como as empresas, têm uma
cultura e todas elas se concentram
tremendamente em sua estrutura,
eles colocam um esforço enorme para tornar
a estrutura mais eficiente,
infelizmente, apenas uma fração de  o
mesmo esforço vai para a cultura, o que significa
que eles perdem grandes
oportunidades de criatividade, inovação
e pura felicidade que a cultura pode para
você se você se concentrar na boa
cultura de aprendizado, ela pode trazer o quarto, de
acordo com nossa experiência e número
de benefícios eficácia
compromissos éticos  mas certamente também o
compromisso com a criatividade e a comunidade
todos nós nas organizações temos a necessidade de
melhorar para tornar isso  ngs melhor para fazer as
pessoas se unirem também há um
grande desejo por isso na maioria das organizações
e certamente há potencial em tudo o
que todos precisamos melhorar esse é o
chamado deles não necessariamente porque as
coisas estão tão ruins, mas porque elas
podem obter uma cultura melhor  é algo que
todas as organizações têm a maneira como fazemos as
coisas por aqui o que está pendurado na
parede por assim dizer é moldado pela nossa
história é algo que nos diz as
expectativas escritas e não escritas sobre o
que é real o que é verdade e o que é
importante real  verdadeiro e importante,
afeta a maneira como pensamos, como nos sentimos e
certamente também como agimos; se queremos
ser bons e ter sucesso no futuro,
precisamos descobrir quais são os
lados positivos de nossa cultura e também quais são
as sombras e como podemos  vamos
mudar e moldar o futuro d hawk
quando falou de cultura e
criatividade falou de normas atitudes
metodologias e práticas tudo o
que está imerso no cha  os malícia
e uma das coisas que
aprendemos foi que a boa cultura certamente
pode apoiar e encorajar o
aprendizado individual e coletivo, mas
como detectamos nossos valores como
encontramos bem esses princípios que têm a
ver com o que o falcão nos disse de acordo
para a história do jeito que me lembro alguns
anos atrás do jeito que me lembro ele
estava na sala e disse que quando eu era
jovem um pouco da coincidência
acabei sendo diretor de uma agência
de um banco em algum lugar  América, não
demorou muito até que eu fosse convocado junto
com outras pessoas para avaliar uma ideia bastante nova,
o cartão de pagamento,
havia um senso geral de concordância de que
o cartão de pagamento tem muito
potencial, mas ninguém realmente entendia
seu mecanismo.  realmente se entendia
como fazer com que fosse um sucesso nem mesmo quais
são os talvez os desafios em torno
deste nas reuniões o mesmo consenso
apareceu mas também houve um certo
tipo de desacordo sobre o que são  os
problemas de onde eles vêm quais
são as consequências desses problemas
qual é de fato a natureza desses
problemas então um jovem falcão sugeriu
eventualmente que eles formariam uma
força-tarefa para resolver esses problemas e você
sabe como essas coisas acontecem isso é um  grande
idéia filho você faz isso de
repente ele entendeu ele era um ponto para o
líder da força-tarefa teve que montar
uma equipe e começar a investigar qual
era o escopo e alcance desses
problemas eventualmente a conclusão foi
clara que havia de fato problemas enormes
eles  estavam perdendo dinheiro dinheiro muito dinheiro
rápido e eles precisavam fazer algo para que
seu mandato fosse estendido não apenas para
analisar os problemas, mas para encontrar uma
solução o que sua equipe fez foi que ele
começou a desconstruir o processo
que levou até aquele dia em que  eles enfrentaram
todos esses desafios, mas também olhar
para o futuro o que é necessário
para torná-lo um sucesso anos depois,
quando refletiu sobre esses eventos e
quando olhou para  o sucesso do visto
ele transformou isso em filosofia e
metodologia que agora compartilhou conosco
e o que ele disse foi que normalmente o que
acontece é que as pessoas começam a fazer
coisas que iniciam executam a prática
logo começam a procurar como podemos fazer
isto melhor mais rápido mais fácil mais barato muito
quanto à eficiência da estrutura se isso
não corresponder às esperanças que você tem
comece a olhar para as pessoas se elas
têm as habilidades certas elas têm as
competências certas nós temos as
pessoas certas ele depois de um  enquanto você
começa a se perguntar se temos o
desenho organizacional correto temos
a configuração legal correta qual é o nosso
modelo de negócios estamos
no negócio certo se isso não for suficiente
você vai um passo mais fundo e
começa a questionar talvez  o problema é
que não acreditamos nas mesmas
coisas não concordamos sobre o que é importante
não compartilhamos os valores básicos só depois
disso você faz a pergunta mais importante
por que qual é o propósito  e por
que existimos o que nos propusemos a
realizar o que nascerá para se
tornar suas descobertas e experiências
sugeriram que você precisava reverter
esse processo de projeto
e você precisa começar a se perguntar
por que isso é importante qual é o nosso
propósito se  tudo é possível o que
deve se tornar somente quando você
chegar a um acordo sobre isso, você deve se mudar para
o principal e encontrar esses
entendimentos básicos gerais desse sistema de crenças
que você compartilha e que você acha que pode
apoiar essa oração que antes desculpe
esse propósito quando isso for feito você
entra no conceito e no conceito você
começa a descobrir o que é
necessário para aproveitar e realmente levantar esses
princípios, depois disso você tenta encontrar
as pessoas que acreditam no mesmo
propósito que compartilham as mesmas convicções
e que podem realmente impulsionar o  conceito
então na estrutura como faço para que
as habilidades e competências dessas
pessoas saiam da melhor forma possível
e só então pratico isso foi o
fi  descobertas que ele compartilhou conosco e essa
também foi a tarefa que ele nos apresentou
Eu quero que você passe pelo mesmo
processo não ia ser tão fácil
na verdade foi muito difícil muito difícil
na verdade havia tantos altos e
baixos de volta e  para dentro e para fora três
passos para a frente para um passo atrás infelizmente
também quando você passou por
todo o círculo começa tudo de novo
uma renegociação completa do que é
tudo isso até hoje
usamos a mesma metodologia e campo de
filosofia  quando trabalhamos em projetos e
também quando fazemos nossa própria
mudança organizacional para que o impacto dos
ensinamentos de Hawks não possa ser subestimado
superestimado desculpe por isso
superestimado quando quando
terminamos esse processo algo surgiu
e algo que é importante em termos
de  cultura de aprendizagem o nosso propósito está
orientado para o crescimento e está enraizado na
aprendizagem como tal para que encontremos
os princípios desses valores que
constituem a nossa le  cultura de aprendizado
começamos a nos perguntar o que é uma ótima
questão o que é uma ótima questão para
realmente descobrir
a cultura de aprendizado e a questão que
podemos chutar o software era o que
constitui uma ótima cultura de aprendizado o
que é necessário para que as pessoas se
apoiem  compartilhar contribuir envolver-se e
realmente assumir a responsabilidade e elevar-
se o resultado desse exercício
acabou se transformando em
compaixão equilibrada brincalhão
assumir riscos no mundo real e ser
esperto  cultura de aprendizagem e cultura de aprendizagem impactante
, você precisa descobrir para
onde está indo, por que isso é importante,
qual é o propósito disso e em
que realmente acreditamos que as ações que
podem apoiar essa cultura
de aprendizagem, todas as culturas de aprendizagem estão
enraizadas  valores os valores podem estar
ocultos para nós podem não ser detectados
que certamente estão lá podem
estar em nossas práticas podem estar em  uma
estrutura eles podem estar em nosso currículo,
mas eles estão lá para criar
essa cultura de aprendizado você precisa
descobri-los você precisa descobrir o que
eles são você precisa descobrir como
viver com eles navegar e também como
desafiá-los como  para questioná-los e
às vezes ir por aí e mudá-los
às vezes você precisa ser um pouco louco se
você quer mudar o mundo para um
lugar melhor você precisa ser um pouco louco se você
quer criar novos futuros e se você
quer impactar o mundo  status quo é
assim que é se você quer progresso e
inovação você pode ter que ficar um pouco
louco de vez em quando a vida e a cultura
andam de mãos dadas e se você quer uma
grande cultura você precisa alimentá-la
alguém disse que a educação que a vida  é
uma educação bem certamente a educação
também deve ser a vida muito obrigado
cuide bem de
você